Ja sam Alec Baldwin a vi ste sekunde
udaljeni od gledanja
novog crtanog filma iz radionice snova, Boss Baby (beba šef).Ja sam tako uzbuđen zbog vas. Stvarno. Imam sve te leptiraste osjećaje u svom stomaku. Krenimo.
*Music Playing* Temperments-i su načinili plan za njihovo najnovije izdanje.
Što to?
I, upoznoj svog novog brata.
Ali ova beba... ima druge planove
Mi bebe imamo krizu! Bebe više nisu voljenje, kako smo nekad bile.
Pogledajte našeg smrtnog neprijatelja ... Štenci.
AWWWW
Ne!  Upravo je to problem!
*Music Playing*
Jesi li naučio išta?
A B C D
Ne, što si naučio o štencima?
Jee štenci!
Ne, Jimbo, Štenci su zli.  Stacey, čitaj bilješke!
Ne znam čitati. Što piše?
Šefe! Roditelji!!
Aww.Izgleda da imaju njihov mali sastanak.
*Babbling*
Ovo je tako ponižavajuće!
Imam zadatak za kompaniju. Zadatak? Ti možeš govoriti!!! Aaaa g.. dužnost.
AAAAA. Moram se riješiti brata.   Tko si ti? Ja sam na
zadatku gdje nije dovoljna samo ljubav za poći okolo
moj posao je saznati zašto mi ne daju
dupli espreso i vidjeti da li ima
neko mjesto uokolo sa desentnim sušijem
Ubio bih za začinjenu rolu s tunom upravo
sada
ovo je rat.
Gledaj djeca se napokon
lijepo slažu. To je lijepo.
Ako ne uspijem u ovom zadatku ja ću
živjeti ovdje zauvijek s vama
U redu, pomoći ću, ali samo zato da te
se riješim. Dogovoreno. Evo ti dolazi ću ću vlak. Ne, ne.
Oni nas gledaju. Hvala
U redu, ću ću na to. Kako možemo proći stražu?
Nikad nisam bio tako ponižen u svom životu
na ovaj način
bolje donesi što ću oblačiti. Obuci se.
Što si mi učinio?
što su sve ove rakete.  Nije li neodoljiv?
hoou
Imam i za tebe jedan. Što? Nesreća.
On radi s grmastom bebom: Ostavi taj kolač
dolje
kolači su za odjelaše.
Pogledaj ga! On nosi odijelo.
On je kao mali čovjek. On nosi
poslovnu torbu.
Nema nikog tko bi mislio da je to, ma ne
znam, malo nakazno
hoćeš li ti brinuti  o janjetu uokolo sve dok ti se ne
svidi. Ovdje se ne radi o janjetu!